es una advertencia clara dirigida a joe
biden china no tiene intención de hacer
confesiones con el tema de taiwán
eeuu debe actuar y hablar con cautela
sobre la cuestión de taiwán y abstenerse
de enviar señales erróneas a las fuerzas
separatistas de ese país esto para
evitar dañar seriamente las relaciones
chino-estadounidenses
no se oponga a los 1400 millones de
chinos este mensaje llega después de que
el presidente by ben dijera que su país
defendería a taiwán en caso de que china
intentará hacerse con el control de la
isla autogobernada una declaración que
contradice la política exterior de eeuu
que ayuda a construir defensas en taiwán
sin prometer explícitamente su
asistencia en caso de guerra no obstante
la casa blanca aseguró más tarde que su
postura al respecto no ha cambiado china
considera a taiwán como territorio
nacional y ha prometido controlarla
algún día utilizando la fuerza si es
necesario con 23 millones de habitantes
taiwán es una de las democracias más
progresistas de asia y la presidenta
chagin wen ha rechazado la propuesta de
chimpín de establecer el modo de un país
con dos sistemas independientes como en
el caso de hong kong y macao su negativa
está enfadando a beijing que ha
intensificado las maniobras militares
cerca de la isla haciendo volar aviones
de combate en el espacio aéreo de taiwán
y navegando con buques de guerra a su
alrededor desde el pasado mes de
septiembre se han realizado más de 800
vuelos y sobre lo que va de mes 170